mit kanonen auf spatzen schießen sind
denn die befürchtung der kanzlerin und
mancher virologen übertrieben oder kann
man gar nicht vorsichtig genug sein
unterwegs in geheimer mission wir haben
es gerade gehört ist die mutation bei
117 ansteckender als die bisherigen
übeltäter aus der wir uns familien
gleichzeitig scheint die
leidensbereitschaft im land zu sinken
von home office bis ausgangssperre was
wird verschärft jetzt die phoenix runde
zu den ergebnissen der bund länder
beratungen
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst hier im studio eva quadbeck ist
bei uns stellvertretende chefredakteurin
und leiterin des hauptstadtbüros des
redaktions netzwerks deutschland ein
zusammenschluss mehrere zeitungen
professor marcel fritsche leitet das
deutsche institut für
wirtschaftsforschung diw und
zugeschaltet professor gernot marx
direktor ausarten direktor der klinik
für operative intensivmedizin an der
uniklinik in aachen und sie sind auch
neuer präsident der deutschen
interdisziplinären vereinigung für
intensiv und notfallmedizin und
schließlich noch dabei mein kollege
frank bräutigam aus karlsruhe leiter der
ard rechts redaktion herr marx was sie
da gerade gehört haben von der
bundeskanzlerin von den beiden
ministerpräsidenten war das aus ihrer
sicht eher halbherzig was da angesichts
der pandemie lage beschlossen worden ist
oder war das ein wichtiger schritt den
wir jetzt gehört haben auf den richtigen
weg
also ich bin sehr froh dass die
maßnahmen der des logins verlängert
worden sind bis zum 15 februar
warum ist das so wir sind zwar über den
tag hinaus die zahlen gehen runter wir
hatten ja den maximalwert von 5800
intensivpatienten anfang des jahres ja
und wir haben auch den peak von
weihnachten gesetzt an dem wir
befürchtet haben nicht gesehen aber
immer noch 5019 patienten zu all den
anderen patienten zu versorgen haben
also es ist alles andere als entspannung
und deswegen begrüße ich begrüße die
deutsche intensiv medizin besonders dass
die maßnahmen fortgeführt werden und
offen gestanden
eine richtige alternative um die zahlen
noch weiter zu senken habe ich auch
nicht gesehen
von kurt beck bei dem für und wider
dieser antico roma maßnahmen ist die
politik da in einer selbstverschuldeten
zwickmühle
auf jeden fall jetzt fällt der regierung
und auch aus den dem bund und den
ländern auf die füße was sie im herbst
versäumt haben
man hätte im oktober einmal in einen
harten lockdown gehen können damals
hat man gezaudert weil man sich nicht
getraut hat nach dem motor waren sommer
der entspannung einfach zu sagen wir
brauchen diesen job down wieder und dann
ist ja im november so ein halber
lockdown gemacht worden den keiner ernst
genommen hat und dementsprechend hat
sich auch keiner so verhalten wie man es
hätte tun müssen um das virus zu stoppen
und dann auch selbst der dezember hat ja
noch nicht sofort den durchschlagenden
erfolg gebracht jetzt langsam sieht man
die zahlen runter gehen und das hätte
man wirklich zu einem kleineren preis
haben können
und auch jetzt ist die politik nicht in
der lage wirklich entschlossen
vorzugehen
die kanzlerin hat zwar gerade sehr
entschlossen gesprochen aber wenn man in
das papier ein guckt wozu ich heute
schon gelegenheit hatte dann sieht man
doch dass da auch der ein oder andere
gummi paragraf dabei und es ist und es
immer noch schlupflöcher für die länder
gibt die dinge genau so auszugestalten
wie sie das eben für richtig halten
das war ja ein reizwort ist die home
profis nicht auch da gibt es ja jetzt
eine verpflichtung wie kann so sein es
muss gemacht werden soll gemacht werden
dort wo es möglich ist wenn es nicht
stattfindet gibt es auch
sanktionsmöglichkeiten
die unternehmen sind da eigentlich der
gegner sagen das ist ein eingriff in die
unternehmerische freiheit wie wir unsere
arbeit organisieren ein kapitalistisches
großreich wie die schweiz hat mit der
home office pflicht kein problem warum
tun wir uns schwer
na ja das ist natürlich nicht möglich
für den staat zu entscheiden welche
berufe ich ja beschäftigte jetzt zu
hause aus arbeiten kann oder nicht das
kann nur ein unternehmen entscheiden
aber die kritik an ein unternehmen ist
gerechtfertigt denn wenn man das mit der
ersten welle der pandemie vergleich dort
hatten wir eine viel höhere anzahl an
menschen die im home-office waren das
tun jetzt weniger es kann mir keiner
erklären dass es im märz 2020 möglich
aber nicht im januar 20 1 und 2 25
prozent waren damals im home office sind
etwa die hälfte
jetzt kann man sagen 13 prozentpunkte
das ist doch nicht so viel doch das ist
sehr viel das ist gerade entscheidend
jede hebel in bewegung zu setzen
und das hat ja dann auch viele effekte
dass weniger menschen im öffentlichen
nahverkehr sind dass man also auch hier
die die inzidenz herunterbringen kann
und deshalb halte ich das gut dass man
man hat ja jetzt nicht von einem zwang
gesprochen also jedes unternehmen muss
jetzt das machen und sonst eine
ausnahmegenehmigung haben und meine
sorge ist dass diese androhung von
rechtlichen schritten nicht ausreichen
wird um diesen home office anteil hoch
zu bekommen also ich bin eigentlich von
der von den heutigen entscheidung
enttäuscht weil es eigentlich ein weiter
so ist und ich sehe einen grundlegenden
widerspruch in der argumentation man
sagt dass er die bundeskanzlerin eben
sehr klar gemacht wir machen jetzt die
maßnahmen weiter
aus vorsorge vor einer mutation die viel
ansteckender sein könnte aber wenn man
wirklich vorsorge betreiben will dann
müsste man eigentlich maßnahmen nochmals
verschärfen
auch ausgangssperren auch gerade im
bereich home office dass man das noch
mal stärker durchsetzt und deshalb
glaube ich ist es wieder das prinzip
hoffnung also da bin ich komplett bei
ihm an hat im oktober zu spät gehandelt
und das kann sich sehr gut vorstellen
das ist auch jetzt wieder heißt ja hätte
man doch im januar dann lieber mal
härter gehandelt und es kann sein dass
wir dann diese maßnahme im februar oder
märz also wenn die inzidenz neben nicht
runtergehen und sich damit ja auch diese
ganzen beschränkungen auch entsprechend
verlängern
ab heute kann recht haben und recht
bekommen ist ja oft nicht das gleiche
das gilt auch in der pandemie sind denn
auch diese habe man die heutigen
beschlüsse ansieht sind jetzt die
grenzen des verfassungsrechtlers
ausgereizt gerade was die einschränkung
von grundrechten angeht naja man reizt
sie schon sehr lange aus ein beispiel
dafür ist vor allem sind vor allem diese
ausgangssperren die waren jetzt heute
abend nicht singt thema dieser runde im
kanzleramt
aber man hat ja gemerkt schon in der
letzten zeit um die länder können bei
diesen punkten ohnehin eigenmächtig
entscheiden die umsetzung der
einschränkung ist ländersache und
deswegen gibt es ja zum beispiel hier in
baden württemberg auch schon die
ausgangssperre und abends nach 20 uhr
darf man nur noch einen unter triftigen
gründen raus
und damit reizt man schon die grenzen
aus grundrechte einzuschränken
das geht wirklich nur deswegen weil die
zahl noch hoch sind und diese unsichere
lage wie die mögliche mutation also das
sind hebel wie man diese einschränkungen
so gerade noch begründen muss und wir
haben ja gesehen man konnte sich auf
deine einige die eine linie einigen bei
diesen punkt aber es ist auch wichtig zu
wissen diese konferenz bundeskanzlerin
und ministerpräsidenten die kann selbst
dort in berlin sowieso nichts
entscheiden die umsetzung liegt immer
bei den ländern und man hat es ja auch
bei den letzten konferenzen gemerkt dann
war was in den papieren drin und einen
tag später hat man schon gemerkt dass
das in einzelnen ländern auch weiterhin
anders umgesetzt wird unterschiedlich
und das ist auch weiterhin immer möglich
zum beispiel bei diesen ausgangssperre
jetzt gilt das natürlich ganz besonders
für den bildungsbereich
was frank bräutigam da gerade gesagt hat
das ist er wird zum richtigen zankapfel
heute geworden dass ja auch der grund
für die ganze verzögerung der beratungen
gewesen und dass wir jetzt auch ein teil
noch unsere sendezeit opfern mussten für
die pressekonferenz ist da was wir
gerade schon besprochen haben dieses
zögerliche dieses nicht entschiedene
vorgehen da es gibt 16 kultusminister
jeder hat eine eigene vorstellungen 16
regierungschef in den ländern jeder der
eigene vorstellung wie schule zu
funktionieren hat in seinem bundesland
zeigt dass wieder dass man sich
vielleicht in diesen bei denen bei den
ministerpräsidenten noch immer noch
zögerlich ist aus wahlkampfgründen aus
politische taktiererei oder einfach weil
man von der reaktion der bevölkerung
irgendwie angst hat und das hat ja
unbedingt bei der auswirkungen auch auf
die familien zum beispiel wie es wie es
jetzt mit dem dem schulbetrieb
weitergeht
das hat natürlich auch etwas mit den
sehr unterschiedlichen lagen in den
ländern zu tun ist es ja nach wie vor so
dass wir die bundesländer haben mit sehr
hohen instanzen und dann mit welchen
muss sehr viel passabler aussieht also
zwischen 80 und 230 an incidents also
diese neuinfektionen ich sage es noch
mal in sieben tagen pro 100000
einwohnern dass es sehr unterschiedlich
und dann wird es auch politisch anders
betrachtet also die spd-geführten länder
die seen schulpolitik auch stärker noch
als sozialpolitik als es oft bei den
unions ministerpräsidenten der fall ist
die sagen dann die kinder müssen zur
schule gehen damit sie nicht
vor allen dingen wenn sie aus sozial
schwierigen verhältnissen kommen
zu hause sind dort möglicherweise gar
keine technischen möglichkeiten haben
sich in einen sich in den digital
unterricht einzuklinken oder auch es
stress in den familien gibt also dass es
eben auch ein wichtiger
sozialpolitischer aspekt und auch jetzt
ist es so dass im grunde genommen man
nicht so richtig einen schritt weiter
ist die kanzlerin hat zwar gesagt wir
haben das jetzt verbindlich gemacht aber
wenn man in das papier von dezember
nochmal hinein guckt da war es auch so
dass man gesagt hat man hebt die
präsenzpflicht in den schulen auf und
dann entscheiden eben die länder wie sie
damit umgehen mit dieser aufgehobenen
präsenzpflicht und manchmal entscheiden
auch einzelne schulen und sagen werden
dass aufgehoben habe im grunde genommen
erwarten wir dass er erscheint das war
das was die kanzlerin gerade
angesprochen hat dass sie das
unterbinden möchte aber das wird ihr im
grunde genommen nicht so gelingen dass
das wirklich dann flächendeckend
durchgesetzt
die kompetenz dafür ja auch nicht hat in
der bildungspolitik herr marx wir haben
ja also das besser gesagt die
schulschließungen dienen ja oder die
diskussion über schulschließungen
kombinieren ja um die frage recht auf
bildung contra gesundheitsschutz
jetzt haben wir schon von diesem von
dieser mutation bei 117 gesprochen dass
besonders bei kindern offensichtlich
sich zeigt auswirkt und die sind dann
auch wir als träger und können dann eben
von der schule ausgehend die eigene
familie oder die verwandtschaft
anstecken
ist das nicht ein plädoyer was dafür
jetzt wirklich konsequent zu mindestens
für die nächsten vier wochen die schulen
zu schließen damit sich genau diese
mutation die etwa bei glaube ich ein
prozent der erkrankungsfälle in
deutschland nachgewiesen ist damit sich
diese mutation nicht weiter ausbreiten
kann
also es ist völlig richtig diese
mutation ist wirklich ein neuer großer
unsicherheit und risikofaktor der eine
große gefahr darstellt und die
schulschließung oder wir haben als die
wie auch gesagt ist es besonders wichtig
dass hier wirklich deutschlandweit hier
die gleichen maßnahmen schließen und an
einen strang ziehen und das gilt eben
auch für die schulen ja und es geht
darum kontakte zu vermeiden
und infektions vermeiden deswegen gut
ich bin jetzt medizinern kein schul und
pädagoge aber die gefahr der verbreitung
durch schul öffnungen halte ich für
gegeben und sollten wir möglichst
vermeiden
und wenn ich das noch sagen darf wir
haben ja jetzt noch 5000 patienten auf
unseren intensivstation mit 19
damit das auf den weg der ersten welle
sich senken kann werden wir noch bis
mitte ende februar benötigen und sie
haben ja vielleicht die bilder aus
london oder aus spanien gesehen wo die
rettungswagen vor den krankenhäusern vor
den notaufnahmen manchmal stunden warten
bis sie die patienten versorgt bekommen
das sind bilder die wollen wir in
deutschland nicht haben
diese belasten überbelastung die müssen
wir unbedingt war hinhalte deswegen
denke ich auch es ist eben die
konsequenter wir jetzt kontakte
vermeiden desto besser ist es wird schon
noch mal zum home office sind damit
eigentlich unzufrieden
es sind im moment 13 prozent im
home-office 27 prozent war sie in
deutschland gibt es 42 millionen
sozialversicherungspflichtige jobs
glaube ich dann sieht man welche und von
welchen größenordnungen widersprechen
dass das nicht so funktioniert und
wenigstens nicht diesen wert vom
frühjahr bekommt wie kann man denn
tatsächlich das durchsetzen was da heute
beschlossen worden ist ist das zu
schwach im beschluss ist da ist er nicht
durchsetzungsfähig genug oder müsste man
eben einfach mehr kontrollieren kann man
das überhaupt kontrollieren
man kann es nicht kontrollieren deshalb
halte ich eine art zwang für falsch
sondern muss letztlich mit den
unternehmen arbeiten mit der wirtschaft
arbeiten und sagen wie können wir euch
helfen
damit ihr das umsetzt also ich glaube
man muss eine akzeptanz bei den
unternehmen finden gegen den willen der
unternehmen wird es nicht gelingen weil
wie wollen sie als staat im unternehmen
nachweisen dass genau dieser mitarbeiter
jetzt nicht ins büro kommen muss sondern
von zu hause aus arbeiten können ist
können sie eigentlich nicht und deshalb
müssen sie die unternehmen mitnehmen
die schwierigkeit das kann man auch
nicht stark genug betonen wie sind heute
einer ganz anderen wirtschaftlichen lage
ist noch vom ja viele unternehmen haben
nicht mehr die rücklagen viele
unternehmen kämpfen um ihr überleben
und wenn es jetzt für unternehmen heißt
sie müssen dicht machen weil die
menschen nicht mehr zur arbeit kommen
können dann ist das für viele
unternehmen existenziell und das müssen
wir uns auch bewusst machen
also warum es im interesse dann auch
dieser das ist ja dass man den leuten
sagt ihr müsst das so hinbekommen weil
die alternative ist dass wir noch einen
härteren lockdown haben in vier oder
acht wochen
und dann ist der schaden noch größer
also ich glaube die botschaft die man
nicht häufig genug betonen kann
es besteht kein widerspruch zwischen
schutz der gesundheit auf der einen
seite und schutz der wirtschaft auf der
anderen seite für die wirtschaft ist es
essentiell dass diese zweite welle
gestoppt werden kann so schnell wie
möglich dass dann ein neustart wieder
möglich ist
denn das was im augenblick passiert es
ist ja nicht so dass nur die direkt
betroffenen unternehmen also restaurants
einzelhandel reisebranche betroffen
sondern auch viele andere die nicht die
gleichen umsätze haben und denen zu
sagen wir müssen jetzt gucken dass diese
zweite welle gestoppt werden kann damit
ein neustart ein wirtschaftlicher
neustart möglich ist also auch immer
wieder betonen ist besteht hier kein
widerspruch sondern letztlich sind das
zwei seiten der gleichen medaille mit
dem home office sagen man darf also ich
will überhaupt nicht in abrede stellen
dass viele unternehmen das nur
schleppend umsetzen oder nicht mehr
umsetzen wollen
es gibt aber sehr viele arbeitnehmer die
anders als im frühjahr sehr gerne ins
büro gehen weil eben die sozialen
kontakte fehlen und menschen die alleine
leben dann sagen hauptsache ich kann
noch ins büro gehen also dass davon habe
ich sehr oft gehört und reiber ist
natürlich deswegen diese einstellung
auch in der kantine zum beispiel sind
nicht immer nur die arbeitgeber sind
teilweise auch die arbeitnehmer die
sagen ich möchte jetzt aber ich glaube
genau das ist der probleme muss
unterscheiden zwischen beschränkungen
des arbeitsleben des wirtschaftlichen
leben und des privatlebens und ich
glaube da muss eine abwägung gemacht
werden und wenn wir gut man kann sagen
das privatleben ist wichtiger als das
arbeitsleben aber wenn wir
wirtschaftlich schützen wollen dann muss
man sagen es müssen eigentlich viel
stärker beschränkungen privatleben her
damit eben die wirtschaft einigermaßen
weiterlaufen kann das auch arbeitsplätze
gesichert werden können
denn darum geht es letztlich es geht
letztlich auch um arbeitsplätze der
bräutigam bindet uns mal in diesem
aspekt home office etwas raus greifen
die kenn ja berichtete eva quadbeck hat
es gerade schon angesprochen wo es
streit in einem unternehmen gibt wo sich
der chef weigert die
mitarbeiter ins home office zu lassen
obwohl die der meinung sind sie könnten
da gut arbeiten wenn es jetzt diese
bestimmung die da heute verabschiedet
worden ist die nach rechtlicher etwas
diffus ist und vielleicht auch etwas
weiß kann den ein arbeitnehmer
tatsächlich rechtlich eine home office
tätigkeit erzwingen oder zumindest von
einem gericht überprüfen lassen
also wir müssen uns diese regelung der
noch sehr frisch ist nochmal genau
angucken aber das lohnt sich wirklich
denn wir haben ja jetzt den übergang von
appellen zum home office zu so ist es
zumindest heute gesagt war in einer
verordnung also einer gewissen
rechtlichen verbindlichkeit und da ist
ihr gespräch gerade sehr spannend
gewesen
diese beiden perspektiven die pflicht
des arbeitgebers das zu ermöglichen
vielleicht auch begründen zu müssen
warum dass die tätigkeit ausnahmsweise
nicht zulässt auf der seite des
arbeitnehmers habe ich die kanzlerin so
verstanden dass da gesagt würde die
können sie bitten wir dieses angebot
dann anzunehmen
also ich sehe stand heute abend keine
pflicht der arbeitnehmer aufs home
office sondern ein recht das heißt wenn
die leute sagen wollen ich möchte lieber
ins büro dann könnte das wieder zu
zerreißprobe führen das ist aber eine
vorläufige bewertung insgesamt ist an
diesem heutigen abend aus rechtlicher
sicht dieses home office thema wirklich
das spannendste und das ist auch das was
noch am meisten folgefragen praktisch
und rechtlich in den nächsten tagen und
wochen aufwerfen wird ist denn das aus
sicht der unternehmer betrachtet ein
eingriff in die freiheit unternehmens
freiheit dh der freizügigkeit da steht
ja in den ersten 20 artikeln des
grundgesetzes also bei den grundrechten
die freizügigkeit auch die
unternehmerische freiheit ist das ein
eingriff wenn der staat jetzt sagt oder
die politik gezeigt und die behörden
sagen wir du bist verpflichtet home
office zu machen du musst uns jetzt gut
begründen warum das nicht machen
möchtest also ein eingriff ist das auf
jeden fall in die unternehmerische
freiheit das ist ja bei ganz vielen
grundrecht kann sowas es eingriffe sind
und juristisch ist dann immer der
entscheidende punkt kann man diesen
eingriff rechtfertigen gibt es dafür
gründe das ist immer der zentrale
juristische punkt man dann eine maßnahme
wie jetzt home office ausgangssperre usw
gerechtfertigt ist und da wird die
politik jetzt die aktuelle infektions
lage die gefahr durch die mutation
anführen also man kann sich das wie die
beiden wagen der justiz ja vorstellen
auf der einen seite die rechte der
unternehmer auf der anderen seite die
gefahrenlage und so begründet die
politik dass die gerichte werden sich
das genau anschauen die erfahrung der
letzten wochen ist aber in dieser
aktuellen lage wo die unsicherheit so
groß ist dass die gerichte da der
politik in den letzten tagen und wochen
noch nicht direkt in die parade gefahren
sind sobald sich das nur ansatzweise
ändert die zahlen weiter zurückgehen und
die sicherheit wo kommt das genau her
größer wird wenn die gerichte auch
wieder stärker eingreifen ist zumindest
meine prognose er marxist es ja so dass
diese dieser mix aus home office masken
pflicht jetzt auch in öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln oder in geschäften jahr
eben die zahlen runter bringen soll das
hat die kanzlerin ja gerade in dieser
pressekonferenz wieder nahezu beschwören
wollen was die masken pflicht angeht
diese verschärfung hilft das
letztendlich auch tatsächlich die zahlen
runter zu kriegen und damit dann auch
weniger menschen dass weniger menschen
in die situation kommen als coop 19
infizierte zb auf eine intensivstation
zu müssen
also ich glaube dass auch in diesem
punkt ist wieder dass das hier eben
konsequent diese maßnahmen durchführen
und das wäre jetzt von diesem
stoffmasken hin zu mund nasen massen
oder ft2 masken gehen ist sicherlich ein
schritt der sicherheit der dazu führen
wird dass wir dann eben auch weniger
infektionen haben werden das denke ich
schon
aber das ist auch wirklich ganz dringend
notwendig weil die kannst dann hat das
ja auch eben angedeutet wir müssen
wieder in die lage kommen die einzelne
infektionen nachzuverfolgen jetzt fahren
wir ja auch eigentlich angefangen zu
sequenzieren wir brauchen quasi so ein
früherer das system um ausbrüche mit
diesem neuen mit dieser neuen virus
mutation bei 117 frühzeitig zu erkennen
es wird landkreise geben wo das
stattfindet und je eher wir feststellen
wo ist das und vielleicht hier dann auch
noch gewisse maßnahmen zusätzlich
treffen können desto länger wird es
dauern bis sich diese bios mutation
verbreitet und an eine wirklich große
gefahr für unser land bedeutet wie
gefährlich ist diese mutation jetzt aus
sicht des in sie
mediziner ist also man vermutet ja sie
ist in deutschland noch nicht weit
verbreitet noch nicht weit verbreitet
muss man sagen wie gefährlich ist sie
wirklich dann gefährlich auch durch die
hohe ansteckungsgefahr was würde
passieren wenn diese ausbreitung dieses
b17 praktisch nicht zu stoppen ist
also man hat ja einen anderen ländern
gesehen dass es eine weile dauert bis
diese mutante letztendlich die
vorherrschende virus art wird das wird
am ende des tages auch in deutschland
wahrscheinlich nur sehr schwer zu
verhindern seien ich hoffe es aber es
wird sehr schwer werden da müssen
wirklich alle diese maßnahmen konsequent
verfolgen und das bedeutet dass der
sogenannte erwert sofort sprunger wieder
ansteigt und wir sofort im
exponentiellen wachstum uns befinden
und deswegen ist für die intensivmedizin
so wichtig dass wir die zahl jetzt
wirklich noch mal ganz ganz deutlich
nach unten bekommen um wieder
aufnahmefähig zu sein
für coop 19 und natürlich auch für alle
anderen kritisch kranken patienten dafür
müssen wir jetzt wirklich sorgen und
deswegen ist je weniger kontakte
wirklich desto besser und es ist
eigentlich ein wettlauf zwischen
impfungen und der virus motivation b 1 1
7 und je mehr zeit wir dafür gewinnen
hier in den menschen wir impfen können
desto schneller kommen wir in einen
zustand zu dem wir eigentlich wieder
kommen wollen um die aufmerksam für
nichts zu schade den letzten monaten
fast eine halbe medizinstudium hier bei
uns auf dem sender absolvieren können
aber nur kurz erklärung er wert ist wie
viele personen eine infizierte person
insgesamt anstecken kann
quadbeck sollte es zu diesen mutationen
kommen und damit zu einer massiven
verschärfung der lage hier in der
pandemie würde das ja den gesamten
optimismus den politiker ja auch immer
vermitteln sollen über den haufen werfen
wird man die menschen dann auch
weiterhin für einstellungen gewinnen
können das problem ist das ja im grunde
genommen seit september die leute immer
wieder vertröstet werden also im oktober
hieß es ja jetzt müssen uns alle
zusammenreißen und dann im november und
dann können wir schon zusammen
weihnachten feiern und hat vor allem die
maßnahmen im november überhaupt nicht
dazu ausgelegt dass man miteinander
weihnachten feiern konnte weil das virus
sich einfach weiter verbreiten konnte
und die verordnung dürfen immer nur vier
wochen verlassen werden also man darf
gar nicht länger den lockdown
beschließen aber trotzdem finde ich es
richtig wenn eine perspektive gegeben
würde und wenn man auch mal ein bisschen
mehr reinen wein einschenken würde und
es wird ja schon so sein dass
beispielsweise die schulen bis ostern
nicht wirklich zu einem flächendeckend
zu einem regelunterricht zurückkehren
können und darauf müssen die schulen ja
auch einstellen also mit hybrid
unterricht und dann können klassen
vielleicht teilweise kommen oder man
sagt die kleinen können wieder kommen
wenn es etwas besser wird aber dass man
damals sagt leute ihr müsst euch
tatsächlich bis zum frühjahr wenn dann
auch vielleicht die impfungen wirken
noch darauf einstellen dass wir pandemie
geschehen haben und zwar gefährliches
pandemie geschehen das fehlt mir in der
kommunikation und das fehlt mir im
grunde genommen seit dem spätsommer und
das führt dann auch dazu dass bei den
leuten die motivation nachlässt dem den
anweisungen und den vorschriften noch zu
folgen weil man nie genau weiß das gilt
jetzt eigentlich welches land er lässt
was und dann hat man immer den eindruck
das ist ja doch alles nicht ganz so
zwingend dass ich dem nachgehen und
diesen beratungen die ja so ungefähr
einmal im monat stattfinden da greifen
die politiker ja gern und politikerinnen
ja gern in den waben besteckkasten dass
man denkt oh wie das kann ja wirklich
etwas besonders dabei herauskommen die
greifen jetzt wirklich zu dann kommt das
ergebnis was so ein bisschen auch
mutlosigkeit jedesmal durchschimmern
lässt wie weit kann die politik dieses
spiel noch treiben
ich denke dass sie jetzt schon an einem
toten punkt angekommen ist und was man
eben auch nicht vergessen darf die leute
das nicht alles mündige bürger und sie
sind von der politik in teilen so ein
bisschen behandelt worden wie kleine
kinder also wenn ihr euch jetzt schön
daran halte dann folgendes anstatt die
leute echt zu überzeugen mit argumenten
und mit zahlen und mit mit dem was die
pandemie auslöst das ist mir zu wenig
dagewesen ein wirkliches erklären dieser
pandemie die kanzlerin hat ganz am
anfang mal eine regierungs ansprache
gehalten und dann der
gesundheitsminister erklärt recht gut
aber ansonsten fehlt das auch dass den
menschen das näher gebracht wird warum
diese maßnahmen so wichtig sind sollte
roger die politik vielleicht auch dazu
übergehen das würde ja vielleicht auch
der wirtschaft helfen auch mal mehr
positive ziele zu formulieren wie wir
aus dieser pandemie
es kommt um einfach auch gemeinsam mit
macht geist und einsicht zu stärken
kommt dazu wenig von den
verantwortlichen politikerinnen und
politikern
das glaube ich nicht ich glaube es sind
zwei punkte wichtig einmal es wird auch
heute in der pressekonferenz immer
wieder von neustart geredet dann können
wir wieder lockern und das weckt doch da
bin ich komplett bei in so eine falsche
erwartungen bald kann es wieder losgehen
bald können wir wieder lockern und das
hören wir jetzt schon seit zwei monaten
erst zu weihnachten und mitte januar und
jetzt ist es mitte februar und zum
reinen wein einschenken also für
unternehmen ist es wichtig
planungssicherheit zu haben sicherheit
hat man nicht das ist klar aber
möglichst wenig unsicherheit und da ist
es wichtig dass die politik erstens sagt
wisst ihr was wir werden uns noch zwei
drei monate auf restriktion einstellen
müssen aber wir als politik stellen alle
möglichen maßnahmen hilfen bereit um
euch zu helfen und die sehen wie folgt
aus
die bundesregierung hat jetzt ein
bisschen nachgelegt über den
überbrückungshilfen 3
die noch ein bisschen großzügig
gestaltet wurden die obergrenzen noch
mal erhöht wurde
aber das reicht eben für viele
unternehmen nicht also ich glaube viele
unternehmen brauchen eine klare ansage
womit an mit welcher unterstützung kann
ich rechnen und auch die klare warnung
ihr könnt euch nicht schnell auf einen
neustart einrichtung wir brauchen einen
langen atem und zu dieser ehrlichkeit
das gehört zur ehrlichkeit dazu klar es
gibt die unsicherheit ist kann ihn
keiner politik hilft und unterstützt und
wird die maßnahme auch noch mal erhöhen
anstelle dessen haben wir diskussion
über die schuldenbremse opfer die jetzt
20 22 wieder einheiten also eine völlig
verquere diskussion jetzt sind wir
mitten in der pandemie und jetzt geht es
darum dass die politik ein klares signal
setzt wir tun was immer notwendig ist um
den unternehmen zu helfen und das so
lange wie es notwendig ist
herr mag diese können wir noch mal zu
der mutation bei 1 17 zurück die so
gefährlich ist diese gefahr wenn die den
menschen immer mehr bewusst wird wenn
sie möglicherweise dieser mutante wie
sie heißt er weiter ausbreitet könnte er
sein dass das auch die impfbereitschaft
bei den menschen weiter erhöht denn auch
eine durchimpfung der gesellschaft
entlastet ja im endeffekt auch die
intensivstationen so dass das
gesundheitssystem wieder stabilisiert
wird
ja das ist richtig
und ich glaube es sind zweierlei ich
glaube ich schon dass die sorge vor
dieser neuen mutation dazu beitragen
wird dass die in freundschaft steigt
aber noch wichtiger ist glaube ich dass
wir informieren aufklären erklären dass
die nebenwirkungen die wir kennen
reversibel sind alle innerhalb von zwei
tagen ja wir kennen keine
langzeitwirkung aber das sind ja seltene
nebenwirkungen man muss immer wieder
sagen wir kennen die wirkung des corona
virus gerade jeder erste ersten welle
jeder fünfte patient dem er stationär im
krankenhaus versorgen mussten ist
gestorben mit 19
mehr als jeder zweite den wir atmen
mussten ist verstorben das sind wirkt
das ist nämlich ein besonders
lebensbedrohliches virus und eine
besonders lebensbedrohliche erkrankung
und als intensivmediziner mache ich
immer eine risiko nutzen abwägung und
der nutzen ist nach meiner einschätzung
so unglaublich viel höher als das risiko
dass sich nur hoffe dass wirklich ganz
viele menschen sich impfen lassen weil
das ist ohne jeden zweifel der weg dass
ihr irgendwann doch wieder zu einer
gewissen normalität finden hoffentlich
dieses jahr bräutigam der bundesminister
für auswärtige angelegenheiten heiko
maas hat in der vergangenen woche für
sich ein neues fachgebiet ausprobiert er
hat nämlich die forderung aufgestellt
dass die die schon geimpft werden oder
geimpft worden sind gewisse sonderrechte
haben also sollten wieder kinos besuchen
und restaurants wie ist das eigentlich
rechtlich zu sehen ist das rechtlich
machbar die die sozusagen selbst wenn
sie nicht mehr infektiös sind selbst
wenn sie sich nicht mehr selbst
anstecken können sonderrechte zu
gewähren oder verstößt das gegen den
gleichheitsgrundsatz in deutschland ja
ein neues fachgebiet der war ja
justizminister eine ganze zeit lang aber
das was sie gerade zuletzt gesagt haben
das ist für diese frage die zentrale
frage die müsste man klären also wenn
man geimpft ist ist man da nicht mehr
anstecken das übersteigt jetzt meine
möglichkeiten dieses szenario aber mal
unterstellt ist das für unsere
gesellschaft in den nächsten monaten
auch im sommer eine ganz zentrale frage
und da prallen freiheit und solidarität
aufeinander
das macht dieses spannungsfeld aus was
meine ich damit wenn man schon
privilegien für geimpfte spricht dann
unterstellt man so ein bisschen das der
lockdown der normalfall ist und die
impfung oder dass man wieder etwas darf
die ausnahme aber wenn man es von den
grundrechten her denkt ist eigentlich
gerade umgekehrt ich habe erst mal alle
rechte und ich brauch gründe um sie
einzuschränken so wenn dieser grund
wegfallen würde ich bin als geimpfter
nicht mehr ansteckend dann kommt der
staat in gewisser weise in begründung
cenote mir diese rechte hinzugehen wo
ich möchte weiter einzuschränken und die
jetzt der zentrale knackpunkt ist ist so
ein grund dass weiterhin ein strikt
einzuschränken der gedanke der
solidarität ich warte solange bis auch
die anderen dran sind gerade wenn der
impfstoff knapp wird und das ist nicht
ganz einfach zu begründen und das kann
auch die gesellschaft zumindest für eine
übergangszeit vor eine gewisse
zerreißprobe stellen meine hoffnung
vielleicht auch eine kleine prognose ist
allerdings wenn immer mehr geimpft wird
und auch die zahlen runter gehen sollten
dann ist der staat ohnehin in der
pflicht nach und nach für alle menschen
die einschränkungen zurückzunehmen so
dass es zu dieser zerreißprobe
vielleicht nur für eine kürzere zeit
kommt dürften denn überhaupt kino und
restaurantbesitzer da sah diese sondern
diese selektion vornehmen und sich die
und gästen den zutritt verwehren weil
sie nicht geimpft sind das wäre ja
möglicherweise auch ein verstoß verstoß
gegen das diskriminierungsverbot
ja da bewegen wir uns ja dann im bereich
des privatrechts also ein privater
restaurantbetreiber der darf erst mal
selbst entscheiden mit wem er übersetzt
juristisch gesagt verträge schließt sie
haben recht das
antidiskriminierungsgesetz
das verbietet diskriminierungen aber
dieses thema impfen ist da noch nicht
aufgenommen da gab es neulich mal die
diskussion aus reihen der spd
ob man das vielleicht ergänzen müsste
das ist noch nicht geschehen
auch nicht ganz so einfach also dieses
recht zu sagen ich lasse hier nur
geimpfte rein da spricht viel dafür dass
das da ist ich frage mich nur ganz
praktisch vielleicht auch was frage an
die vertreter der wirtschaft würde einen
gaststättenbesitzer das wirklich machen
oder ist er nicht froh wenn die leute
wieder rein dürfen machte er dann nicht
lieber an hygiene konzept
und macht gar nicht diese unterteilung
ich bin mal gespannt ich nehme an dass
ab statt dem nicht widersprechen wird
herr marx eine frage doch es hat sich
eine gruppierung namens iroko bildet
also 0 sowie träger in der bevölkerung
die also für ganz radikale forderungen
eintritt also notfalls alles runter zu
fahren wenn alle stricke jetzt reißen
wenn das alles sozusagen nicht mehr
kontrollierbar ist wenn es eher halten
sie es für möglich dass man für einen
begrenzten zeitraum was man was ja
manche schon länger fordern wirklich
alles runter fährt auch die wirtschaft
um zu sagen sonst werden wir der
situation nicht mehr herr
ich glaube wir müssen eben sehr genau
uns die verläufe die analysen anschauen
und dann auch bereit sein wenn nur
wenige neue konsequenzen zu ziehen
bisher muss ich sagen waren waren wenn
man sich den ganzen verlauf des letzten
jahres anschaut haben wir zumindest am
anfang glaube ich sind wir da sehr gut
zusammen durchgekommen und pandemische
zeit das haben wir eben ja auch schon
öfter gesagt eine zeit der ungewissheit
und auch der unwissenheit
wir müssen einfach bereit seien flexibel
dynamisch zu reagieren und die
notwendigen konsequenzen zu ziehen
es wäre vermessen zu sagen das kommt auf
jeden fall oder das kommt auf gar keinen
fall
das muss man abwarten was wir auf jeden
fall verhindern müssen meines erachtens
ist eben solche situationen wie wir sie
gerade in anderen ländern sehen und wie
wir sie am anfang der pandemie zum
beispiel auch in nord italien oder
spanien gesehen haben das sind zustände
die wollen wir in deutschland mit
sicherheit verhindern das wäre für die
wirtschaft eine katastrophe
siroki ja das sind gleich am ende doch
von einem falschen verständnis der
wirtschaft gesundheitssystem
auszustatten grundversorgung
sicherzustellen erfordert eben eine
ganze menge vorleistung und wenn man die
wirtschaft unter fährt dann gefährdet
man auch diese grundversorgung für die
politik wäre das auch
nahezu unlösbar diese aufgabe man kann
die welt nicht anhalten würde auch zu
versorgungsengpässen kommen wir medien
müssen weiter arbeiten also es gibt so
ein paar dinge die jenseits der
gesundheitsversorgung die angehalten
werden könne das ist ein kleiner licht
schimmern
ich bedanke mich bei eva quadbeck bei
professor marcel fritsche bei professor
gernot marx und bei meinem kollegen
frank bräutigam in karlsruhe vielen dank
liebe zuschauer morgen in der phoenix
runde der amtswechsel schafft weiten den
neustart die sendung morgen findet
ausnahmsweise eine stunde später live um
23 uhr 15 statt der grund dafür ist wir
übertragen ja morgen ausführlich die
amtseinführung von joe biden als 46 der
präsident der usa und in diesem zeitplan
eingebettet ist daneben die phoenix
runde um 23 uhr 15 phoenix beginnt
bereits ab 14 uhr live von dieser
amtseinführung zu berichten und jetzt
ist mein kollege michael krons wieder
dran
phoenix der tag und es wird eben wenig
anderes übrig bleiben als über die
beratungen von länderchefs und
kanzlerinnen jetzt noch vertieft zu
sprechen und sie mit weiteren
informationen zu versorgen
es lohnt sich also bei uns zu bleiben
joe biden wird als 6